PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi,
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and this is AI
Simplified, where we
learn to make your data useful.
In the last few
episodes, we have
been covering different
components of Vertex AI
to get you familiar
with different features.
In this video, I thought we
would help a friend of mine
get into yoga.
So we are building a yoga
pose Classification Model
for some simple yoga poses.
This will help her
hone her yoga skills.
First of all, let's see how
we will make this happen.
We need the data to
create our models with.
This would be in
the form of images,
and let's say we
want to focus on five
poses, the Tree, the Goddess,
the Warrior II, Plank,
and Down Dog.
My colleague Sara and I have
collected a bunch of images
from a yoga practice
that we will
be using to train this model.
Our first step would be to
ingest these images using
the Manage Data Sets, and
then label them appropriately.
Then comes training the model.
And since this is an image
classification problem,
it's a good fit for AutoML.
And as we covered
in the last episode,
you can totally create a
custom model from scratch
if you wanted to,
but AutoML is just
the right fit for this
particular Image Classification
problem.
Once our model is
trained, we will
evaluate it to understand
the quality of our model
and indicate areas
of improvement.
Now, AutoML UI
provides us with easy
to understand charts for
this that we will demystify
when I show you the console.
Then, we will need
an endpoint to serve
our models for predictions.
After training our
AutoML model, we
will be able to deploy an
endpoint with just one click.
Now that we have laid
out the data requirements
and how we will
train our model, we
are ready to jump into the
console and make it happen.
First thing we need is the data.
For this step, my
friend Sara and I
collected a bunch of
images from a yoga practice
and uploaded them into
the Manage Data Sets.
As you see here, the images
are labeled in five categories.
I can even upload unlabeled
images and label them.
We can analyze our
data set to see
that we have enough
examples of each categories.
Now, we are ready
to train our model.
In here, I'm selecting
AutoML for training method.
You can also train a model
to deploy on the Edge
or on-premise, or use custom
training if you're writing
your own Custom Model Code.
Now, we define our model.
AutoML automatically
splits the data
into Training,
Validation, and Test,
but we can change
it if you want to.
In Compute and pricing, we get
to select how many node hours
we want to train the model.
At this point, we wait
for the model to train.
Once it is trained, we
see it in the Model tab
and can evaluate the model.
We can see our model's
Average precision.
It ranges from 0 to 1, where a
higher value indicates a higher
quality model.
We can see that the
Confusion matrix
helps us understand where our
model is confusing to results.
Now that we have
evaluated our model,
it's time to deploy
it to an endpoint.
We can split traffic
between two models deployed
on the same endpoint, if needed.
Allocate the number of nodes
needed for this endpoint.
Depending on where
your users are,
select a region to
deploy your endpoint.
And that's it, hit Deploy,
and we have an endpoint.
Now we can test our
endpoint and the model
by uploading an image.
And yay, it works.
You can also make
predictions using the SDK.
All right, so today we created
a yoga pose Classification
Model where we uploaded
our data sets in Vertex AI,
labeled our images in
the UI, and then used
AutoML to train our model.
Then we evaluated it
and then deployed it
for making predictions
with just one click.
I know my friend
will be extremely
happy to use this model
to hone her yoga skills.
Stay tuned for the
next episode, which
is all about using
what Vertex AI SDK.
In the meantime, give
us a like and subscribe,
and share with me your
thoughts about this series
in the comments below.